of course it is now time for the press
preview first look at the papers as they
arrive
it's time to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mirror
columnist susie boniface and the
conservative commentator tim montgomery
and
get this they're going to be here right
through until midnight
sorry guys i hope someone told you about
this uh for our extended
news review uh but first let's take you
through the front pages
that we have pretty much all i think at
the eye reporting that people in certain
areas of
england could have their second covert
vaccinations brought forward
in an effort to contain the spread of
the indian
variant of covert 19 more than that in
just a second
and the telegraph understanding that the
government's vaccine task force
won't be issuing a definitive
recommendation on whether to inoculate
children they're going to be leaving the
decision instead
to the prime minister here's the times
it hears that it could still be
mandatory to wear face masks
even after a possible listening
restrictions on june 21st
and the mail says its campaign to build
a permanent memorial to the victims of
the pandemic at saint paul's cathedral
has now raised enough money to allow the
project to go ahead
and here's the mirror it has word of a
new drug which could combat the effects
of alzheimer's disease big story of true
aliexpress uh it's leading with calls to
ban
firms from hiking prices for customers
who stay with them
for longer the fda is always at
ploughing a slightly different furrow
latest news on inflation
in the united states and here is the
star
it thinks we might be able to save the
planet by working a
four day week as you can see we're
joined by susie boniface and
tim montgomery lovely to see both of you
um and
uh let's start this hour with you tim um
at the front page of the daily telegraph
this is an interesting one i mean the
headline
kind of takes is pretty quite a way
through the story it's it's going to be
the prime minister
who's going to be deciding on whether or
not children receive inoculations
absolutely and up until now the advisory
uh task force on vaccines has sort of
led you know there was that debate you
remember now about whether
vaccines are given first to for example
frontline workers teachers and other
police officers and but they very much
stuck with the general view that the
older groups were most vulnerable they
should get the vaccine first
and since then we've progressed and
through the vaccination program
on age but on this issue this very uh
sensitive issue of whether we vaccinate
children
they aren't going to be definitive
they're going to give the prime minister
and the cabinet
options i give all of us therefore i
hope it will be transparently published
give us all the sort of the information
on what the pros and
cons are of vaccinating children but it
will be ultimately
the government that takes the decision
and of course some people
um want children vaccinated we know
that younger people at the moment are
leading the spread of the indian variant
but at the same time as with the
clotting issue that was associated with
certain vaccinations
do we want to expose children who very
very few cases
and die of covid do we want to expose
them to the
small but nonetheless sometimes real
risks
of a vaccination and so very difficult
decision for the government
are coming up susie do we know because i
can't see it in the article do we know
if the jcvi has done this
of its own volition or perhaps at the
behest of our political leaders i mean
one thing
you don't need to spend long on social
media to discover that there are plenty
of scientists out there at the moment
rather staggered at the lack of
information that is being published
about infection among younger people
yeah and we don't know quite as to why
jcbi have made this decision
i think they've let the public down a
little bit to be honest to say that this
should be down to boris johnson
i don't really trust his opinion about
anything to do with children especially
as he seems to be permanently surprised
when his behavior needs to
keep on turning up um but i think also
he's not an expert in whether or not
children should be vaccinated
uh the experts in that are the jcbi and
so therefore if
if that has to be done or should be done
and safe to be done the therapeutic
benefit
benefits of it outweigh any risks then
then that should be up to the experts
i think the evidence the past year and a
half has proven quite
significantly really that boris johnson
isn't an expert in these things
doesn't so much follow the sciences
follow along about three weeks behind it
sort of shambling along and whistling
and kicking a stone until he feels like
eventually turning up and coming to heal
um and
he's more likely to do i think whatever
the person nearest to him suggests he
does
which in the absence of dominic cummings
is carrie simmons and the absence of her
is probably the dog
so i would i would prefer if the jcbi
made this decision to be brutally honest
um take us then uh tom tim to the um
at the front of the eye um i mean again
there are concerns about the indian
variant although as people are pointing
out we're not seeing hospitals at
capacity
just a significant increase that that
perhaps points the way ahead but if you
if you squint at this story fast second
jags to beat the new variant
i mean in a roundabout way this is a
good story about the vaccine
about the efficacy of the vaccines in
dealing with the indian variant yeah
and i think that's absolutely what
everyone watching this program tonight
should
be reassured by of course we've got to
be vigilant about the indian
variant i think about 75 of new cases
now
are associated with the union variant so
it's absolutely the dominant thread as
we continue to face this uh
covid pandemic but vaccinations
are proving to be effective against it
and we can be really
um reassured about that the government's
next um
initiative is to um reduce the gap
between the first job and the second job
because they have the legitimate
well-founded confidence
in the vaccine if we get people
vaccinated
fully more quickly particularly those
are vulnerable and
will be safer and one of the little
bullet points though in the eye that
attracted my attention was that
still 49 to the british people in a poll
that's been done with the eye
don't want restrictions lifted they're
still very cautious and i think that
communicates a lot about where the
british people really have been
throughout this pandemic
and lots of people particularly in the
media pundits including
people like myself have wanted to lift
restrictions more quickly
because we're worried about the impact
of these restrictions not just on the
economy
but on you know cancer treatments and
the other things that the nhs is so
important for
but i think the public remains very
cautious very concerned about this
pandemic
and i think as the government takes
decisions that probably be way
weighing heavily on their minds susie i
suppose we can link the point that tim's
just made
to the front page of the times and at
the idea that aspects of the the coveted
strategy in particular the
keeping face masks on could persist
after
june 21st i mean if that poll is correct
then perhaps it we won't see the
fireworks that some might predict if
we're all required asked you know to
continue to wear face masks after that
date
yeah the times front page sort of it's a
bit bizarre really because it claims
that you know the government is
thinking about guidance on working from
home and wearing face masks
and frankly whatever the government
rules on this is irrelevant if you want
to work from home you're already doing
it and you're going to keep on doing it
if you don't want to and if you don't
when you're wearing face masks then what
the government says is going to make no
difference
people are working from home anyway
their businesses are making them work
from home
in many cases lots of people prefer it
and i for one i'm going to be keeping my
face mask
probably for the foreseeable every
winter when i go around the place if i
get slighted sniffle most people i know
would say the same thing
um so what the government says about
that is probably fairly irrelevant
and as far as the eye front page is
concerned about the possibility of
having faster second jabs i'm pretty
certain i read that somewhere a week 10
days ago
and it still isn't government policy
it's still something they're just
suggesting
but the little bullet point there that
caught my eye other than the one that
caught tim's was the fact that sage
scientists say this will slow down the
start of the third wave
not stop it not that it's even sort of
you know under discussion anymore we
might even not have a third wave
it just slows down the start
of the next wave which as sage has been
saying for a couple of months now
is going to be over the summer in time
for autumn at the end of
uh lifting restrictions it's exactly the
same predicted sage advice as ever
tim the front of uh the telegraph one of
those stories which you always
slightly raise eyebrows when it gets
snuck out on a friday afternoon of a
bank holiday weekend
but boris johnson well i am i too work
as a broadcast journalist
look boris johnson um cleared of
wrongdoing
but his advisor and standards suggesting
that he acted unwisely and guess which
aspect
of his report number 10 are fixated on
this evening
absolutely well i i'm a conservative i'm
a
supporter of boris johnson in most
respects but i do think this is a very
uh it draws attention to what people
already worry about boris johnson is
that he's just cavalier
with um you know the specifics of
initiatives and specifics of
programs and the very fact that you
could begin to
undertake a refurbishment of your own
living quarters at a cost of 150 200
000 pounds and not be sure about how
it's funded a lot of people watching
tonight will just be scratching their
heads at
how anyone could be considering
embarking on that
scale of expense without knowing knowing
how it's going to be funded so
i think that he's got away the prime
minister's got away with this official
report i thought the
report was a little bit harsh on blaming
officials for not warming
warning the prime minister that he
should be paying more attention
to this but i do think a lot of people
who read about this
will it will confirm their suspicion
that the prime minister
isn't as focused on the detail and the
specifics of things as he should be
not just on this matter but generally
susie
one suspects that you might have a view
on this story
uh if i as a journalist was accused of
bad behavior and was reported to the
press regulator
for considering my ethical behavior and
i then
went and appointed a new head of the
press regulator who subsequently
completely exonerated me of any
wrongdoing
that would be quite rightly called
stitch up and that's exactly what's
happened here it's a stitch up
interestingly throughout gait's report
he uses the phrase that um you know
boris johnson didn't want to burden the
taxpayer
which is entirely a political point to
make something the conservative party
makes a lot
that he had no wish to burn the taxpayer
so he's very kindly footed the bill
himself
he burdened the taxpayer with a minimum
of what the taxpayer has paid of 30
000 pounds to do up an apartment which
had been done up only two years
previously
purely because his girlfriend didn't
fancy the decor um
and that's just not that's not
being kind of the taxpayer in the least
that's doing us 30 grand thank you very
much you should be paying back the whole
lot if he's got 60 grand you suddenly
fan down the back of the sofa you could
pay about the rest can't he
we are going to have to pause there we
do need to get to the break don't worry
you'll have another chance to crack on
with that one pause there for a second
uh but coming up after the break uh does
turning a controversial statue to face
the wall
do anything to address the legacy of it
we'll be discussing that next
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview susie
and tim still here and susie
uh anthony gormley has come up with i
have to say a
fairly innovative suggestion to the
problems of the statue of
uh successful rhodes at oxford
university
yeah he suggested that when we're settle
road statues at the moment above the
gateway it's sort of facing out like a
i don't know like a you know statue in
an alcove that's facing outwards
and gourmet is suggesting that it remain
there but it be turned around and faced
backwards
face the wall as it were to sort of
indicate the shame with which he is
regarded
um but yet to continue acknowledging
that the the college has an awful lot of
um
contact and money and property as a
result of roads riches
now there are tory back bench mps one of
them my friends to john hayes has said
in there this is completely wacky idea
and makes no sense at all um but i think
last time i heard the statue of edward
corston that got thrown in the river in
bristol
uh had been dredged out but was being
sort of preserved
with the graffiti uh to go into a new
museum to sort of
you know tell the story more fully i
suppose
of how that statue sort of went through
a sort of time
span and things that changed to it i
could i think that
using that statue in such a way that you
know we regarded the different public
attitudes towards it during time
would be beneficial i can't see it being
bad put it that way
tim a quick word from you on this i have
to say because my thoughts only extend
as far as total eclipse of the heart by
bonnie tyler it's been going through my
head ever since i
started reading this story and you know
exactly why
well i'm i'm more of a traditionalist on
this and you know i
i think the amount of time we're
spending on what to do with these uh
historic statues is
is a real distraction from what we
really should be doing certainly what
students at oxford should be
focusing on i'm generally in favor of
putting out more statues to honor you
know different kind of heroes
rather than somehow uh destroying or
covering with graffiti
as statues of old and tim's let's stick
with you the times
uh there's wally uh wally the walrus
what else going on with this story
please
oh well this is a lovely story as susie
actually uh picked it out for us and um
most of us are stuck in the united
kingdom at the moment unless we're going
to the champions league final unable to
travel
um abroad but this walrus has drifted
first of all on uh
some sort of ice flow down from the uh
uh
antarctic region i think and been in
ireland been in wales and now in france
and so it seems to be having a wonderful
time and i think a lot of us will be
jealous yeah susie it's the holiday that
i had planned for this year instead of
walrus is taking it and i'm stuck here
in the bank holiday
yeah we have no idea if wally's going to
go on and try and catch the
match in porto if he's heading to the
mediterranean
but he's finding it a lot easier to get
away than the rest of us so power to him
it's going to say it does look a little
bit like a chelsea fan that i know very
well but no
we're all